so I was reading that you were drawn to
this project because it took you out of
your comfort zone the idea of playing an
icon the physicality of the role the
hair and makeup and everything was there
anything that came up along the way that
you didn't expect that really surprised
you as far as challenges go well I
didn't know that we were saying
everything like that was a nice surprise
not know I mean it was I'm really glad I
understand that why he wanted to do that
and I really appreciate that he did now
Judy story is incredibly heartbreaking
but it's also really inspiring and it
was kind of a reminder to me just how
many people out there have kind of
gotten pushed around by the Hollywood
industry a little bit so I was wondering
is that something that drew you to this
project and is that one of the larger
themes you discussed with Rupert a lot
oh yes that was one of the first
questions that I have for him I wanted
to understand why he wanted to focus on
this period in her life
and he talked about contextualizing the
circumstances that she was grappling
with in her final chapter to better
understand that the things that people
lampooned and the things that they would
write about that were so negative and
how they tried to sort of blanket that
period as tragic when you understand the
circumstances and that the circumstances
were the consequence of choices that
were made on her behalf not by her you
know it just really I think exemplifies
how how truly extraordinary she was that
she was able to overcome what seemed to
be insurmountable difficulties that
again were the consequence of of choices
made for her that you can really see how
how really just extraordinary she was
and it also kind of paved the way to
this feeling she had of not knowing how
loved she really was and I appreciate it
in the movie how she finds that love in
people that she didn't really expect so
I'm just curious from your perspective
did you ever have a fan encounter that
you kind of really
needed at that point in your life Oh
certainly people are kind and very kind
and so if ever there's been a question
about whether or not you should share
that story with a person that you're
seeing the answer is yeah you should
share that thing for sure it makes me so
happy to hear I was also reading a lot
about how everybody was just so
enthusiastic about bringing Judi story
to screen on this so was there anybody
on the set that you would kind of
doesn't made the unsung hero we know the
cast we know about Rupert but was there
anybody from you know a PA to someone on
the catering team that just made a
difference in your day because they
worked so hard on oh my gosh every day
every day that whole crew every single
person was there because they had this
connection to Judy or their love for her
and they just wanted to express
affection you know and my thanks to
Andrew who played the piano and worn
from me up and all of the vocal sessions
for sure because he was a great
cheerleader and so kind and Matt Dunkley
who is the composer him too and and Jeff
he's a producer and he was there all the
time too and I felt like impossible
without my guys you know oh and Paul
from from the team they were always
there and so when I had to get up on
stage at the microphone and I would see
them in the background I just felt like
I had like all my stage moms thanks guys
another person this means that I have to
ask you about because she has a lot of
big fans at Collider is Jesse buck oh
come on she's incredible she's way
beyond incredible yes I have her sing
together for fun behind the scenes Mayan
sing with her I just listen I mean she'd
be Howard some Susan Tedeschi in the
morning you know not be like are you
sick Susan Tedeschi and she's like yeah
I'm singing Susan Tedeschi I just wanted
to hear her gosh that woman is a
challenge oh my dream come true is to
see you get a nomination and see her
nominated for wild rose right beside you
Oh lovely oh my goodness that's really
kind thank you that'd be a fun party I
was yeah so clearly this was a very
special
experience for you I'm curious if you
could keep one quality of Judy Garland
that you got to bring on screen in this
movie for you for the rest of your life
what would it be in life how courage it
enables her to hang on to hope and to I
always look to the next good thing that
was going to happen and you know
overcome
let's seem to be insurmountable
difficulty